the guaranteed income is really about
dignity that regardless of your
circumstance you deserve to live a life
that is free of
terror from the the basic necessities of
having to um continually move i i shared
earlier
briefly that i grew up with a single
mother and have a twin brother so she
needed everything double time
for for us and that meant that i took
the back seat um
a lot of times with making requests to
be a part of community or
or extracurricular activities and i was
always cognizant that my mother just
could not afford um
those things and those are those that's
the the stress levels and the
considerations that little children
are impacted by by not having a stable
and
a basic income floor and so i know
firsthand as i said that having a few
hundred dollars extra a month could mean
everything to communities to people that
live in poverty
my mother for one if she i know for a
fact if she had an additional 200
a month that when car repairs came up um
it wouldn't mean that my family had to
move because my mom had to decide
of fixing her car in order to go to work
so that we can continue
moving forward and having to find a new
apartment and so this was a cycle
that i grew up in and that's not
something that any family should deal
with
in the most wealthiest nation of america
we've gotten away from
the the really core values of america
where the american dream was attainable
to all people and we know that that's
not the case especially in a nation
where
uh the wealth rests with the the top one
percent of the population
um and that that just cannot be and
especially when it's
literally physically impossible for
those people to spend that wealth and
even if they spend uh money every single
day
continuously they still can spend all
the wealth that they've acquired and so
it just makes sense to be able to
redirect that money to
the bottom 99 so that people can live
with dignity and that we can jump start
our economy and that we can have
better systems that really um lift the
whole nation as a whole
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you